after months of deliberation planning
and preparation i have compiled a tier
list
of baby yoda's cuteness this was an
extremely hard process
of no sleep and the consulting of top
tier professionals
in this tier lists are 10 of the most
cute baby yoda moments
and some may be a little disturbing you
may be questioning the importance of
this tier list
but figuring out the most cute baby yoda
moments is utterly essential to our
existence
so from that let's look at the first
cute baby yoda moment
looking at the beginning of season 1 we
have the infamous scene where baby yoda
downs a frog
like an alcoholic downs a shot glass
this is really the first moment where
baby yoda becomes the cuteness icon that
he is today
this moment brings in cuteness it brings
in comedy
and baby oda can actually hold his own
he may be thinking that
devouring a frog isn't cute whatsoever
but i'd be
damned if it wasn't cute that this
little guy can eat the entire thing in
one bite
and look at that little face he makes
after finishing his meal
it's as if he wants even more this one
shot a baby gotta looking at din jarn
became a meme overnight
and because of that it makes this moment
even more iconic
then after that look baby yoda delivers
the final cherry on top and gives us a
nice big burp
overall this cute moment deserves a
solid a
going on to the next cute moment we have
the infamous soup sipping
you want some soup although this is a
very simple moment
it doesn't stop baby yoda from
bedazzling the audience
this shot alone immediately steals the
whole scene
this solidifies baby yoda as not being a
one and done actor
and he actually becomes a big sensation
the way he undercuts this intense action
scene with a much needed dose of
cuteness
is perfectly timed a lot of people can
even relate to this moment like when
their parents are fighting
and you're just staring at them while
eating your froot loops
so in general although this moment is
relatively simple
i think it deserves a solid s tier from
how cute
chill and relatable baby yoda is in this
moment
for the next cute baby yoda moment we
have him trying to fly the ship
to start out this scene we have a cute
upside down baby yoda
he's basically solid snake stealthing
around the ship and that thought alone
is priceless but looking at the actual
segment of him trying to fly the ship
it makes for a pretty funny scenario
although this moment
isn't necessarily cute it still makes
for a funny interaction
we were on the verge of greatness we
were this close
although it's immediately interrupted by
denjarin and for that alone
i have to lower it to a b din jaren
should have just let the whole moment
play out and see where baby yoda would
have went
maybe he was trying to go to chuck e
cheese but we'll never know
unfortunately
going on to another big moment we have
baby yoda force choking kara dune
this is where we truly see the evil side
of baby yoda
although this is a little dark it is
still kind of cute that baby yoda is
protecting denjarin from kara
and after the fact he doesn't even know
what he did wrong
he's just being a little kid in his eyes
and he can just see his innocence
but because of the fact that this moment
is more dark than it is cute
i have to put this moment in the d tier
for the next cute baby yoda moment we
probably have one of the most
controversial moments for this
character and that is him eating the
baby eggs
from frog lady although from the
perspective of baby yoda
these moments seem pretty cute but from
the perspective of frog lady
we have a murdering psychopath eating
all of her unborn children
oh baby yoda just ate an egg how cute he
must be so hungry
but in this instance baby yoda is almost
committing genocide because these are
the last eggs of the species
it's her spawn she needs her eggs
fertilized by the equinox or her line
will end
he's doing this all in the name of a
good snack
and i'm sorry baby yoda you may get
hungry at times
but that does not allow you to kill
unborn children
so for that on its own i'll give these
moments a c
and the only reason why these moments
get a c is because of how
god damn cute baby yoda is while
committing genocide
looking at the next episode we have an
immediate redemption arc for baby yoda
while denjarin drops baby oda off at
daycare
he gets to watch babies hatch from their
eggs
baby yoda actually has a character arc
in this scenario
and he learns from his faults of being
blinded by hunger and doing horrible
things from seeing these babies hatch
from their eggs
baby yoda learns that life is precious
and this whole scenario is just really
cute
and with the added benefit of baby yoda
getting to play
with little frog babies
it's also very cute how baby yoda
desperately wanted to stay
and keep playing with the babies the
only downside for this moment is that it
is very short
and the audience just wants more of it
for that alone i think it is fair to
give this moment a solid b
god dammit denjarin you should have
listened to baby yoda and adopted one of
the frog babies so baby yoda could have
a friend
so for the next cute moment we have baby
yoda taking the cookies
in this situation baby yoda is actually
being chill
and asks for a cookie but since the kid
is rude and ignores baby yoda
he takes action
oh these cookies i gotta get the recipe
from liz
put that cookie down now
although it is bad to steal but turning
down baby yoda is basically a crime
against humanity
he shows that stubborn little kid who's
boss and babieta whips out a cookie
and eats one right in his face so that
alone is
badass and freaking cute this is also
one of the main scenes where baby yoda
is completely by himself
in terms of characters and he is still
able to keep things fun
and interesting that paired with him
being very cute in this moment being
very relatable
i'll give this moment a solid a
within the same episode we have another
iconic baby yoda moment
and that is the theme park style ride in
the ship
i think this is essentially peak baby
yoda cuteness
i don't know what they could have done
to make this any better we have baby
yoda vibing and having a great time
him cheering whenever denjarin takes out
a tie fighter
he's showing his priorities of being
hungry and eating cookies
and it even caps off the moment with a
funny reaction to din jarn's crazy
flying with him puking
i just love the thought that baby yoda
is treating this whole moment like a
theme park ride
some people may be turned off by the
fact that baby ota threw up
but it just adds to his adorable factor
that he overdosed on too much
fun and cookies this moment to me
deserves to be in the s tier
going on to the next moment we have baby
yoda being an electrical mechanic
this moment is oddly relatable everyone
has gone through that moment with their
parents where they need help setting up
that tv
and you're the only one small enough to
get behind the tv and plug in different
wires
this moment accentuates that perfectly
and it brings in a nice flare of
cuteness as always
another thing that adds a lot to this
moment is that den jarn and baby yoda
are basically having
a conversation that on its own is
amazing
and that factor really boosts the comedy
baby yoda's just sitting there confused
by the instructions
and denjarin is somehow keeping his
composure
the chemistry between these two pals
boosts the cuteness factor into the
heavens
and i think that this moment deserves a
solid a
for the next cute moment we have baby
yoda eating an exotic meal
poor baby yoda is just hungry and
denjarn has not been allowing him to eat
any more eggs how dare he
so now baby yoda has to eat some yucky
meal in a tavern
but plot twist the kraken is in his bowl
baby yoda is dying in front of his dad
and he just acts like everything is
normal
and he should stop playing with his food
this whole moment is pretty funny
and baby ota really feels like a fish
out of water in this scenario
this moment is both relatable and funny
but it needs a little bit more from that
cuteness
emporium to really give this moment a
higher rank so in that regard
i think this moment deserves a b
for the most unique moment on this tier
list we have baby yoda transcending on
the altar
baby oda may not be making cute faces
and doing adorable things
but the thought and look of baby yoda
becoming an all-knowing entity
is really something else it just
transcends all preconceived notions of
cuteness
and baby yoda becomes the center of the
universe
not even his dad can interrupt his level
of concentration
and din jarn gets yeted into another
dimension
baby yoda in this instance is a god
also there is the added benefit of a few
cute moments
like baby yoda trying to play with
butterflies and him taking a quick power
nap after turning super sand
overall this moment deserves an
outstanding a
the only reason it's not in the s tier
for me is that a lot of the attention
was taken away from this all-seeing god
of cuteness
and was placed mostly on boba fett but
yeah it's still a great moment
for the last cute baby yoda moment we
have his heartbreaking farewell
this is the moment that shatters
everyone's hearts and the ultimate
payoff of denjarin taking off his helmet
melted our inner souls baby yoda finally
got to see his dad's face
and this whole moment is practically
perfect
there is one thing that i can think of
that can be better
and that is the emotion from baby yoda's
facial expressions
to me they looked a little bland but i
don't freaking care dude
this final moment of baby yoda saying
goodbye had more of an emotional
impact than ray skywalker and kylo ren
in the rise of skywalker
you know it's true and i'm not afraid to
admit that this was more emotionally
resonant than that
and i'm prepared to fight anyone in the
comments that disagrees
initially i was going to give this an a
but with the emotionally strong finale
paired with the fact that baby yoda got
to interact with r2d2
and luke skywalker i'll give this an s
this is just truly a perfect send-off to
baby yoda
assuming this is his final scene
so yeah that about wraps up this cute
baby yoda tier list
i know there are technically other
moments from baby yoda that could have
been included
but to me these were the 12 most popular
moments from baby yoda
some honorable mentions would include
baby yoda's relationship with the ball
and him force throwing stormtroopers but
i still think this is a solid list make
sure to like the video
subscribe and comment about what moments
you would put in the s tier and if you
would change anything
i hope you enjoyed the video and if this
jokey cheerless does well i'd be down to
make more like it and i could even apply
it to different shows